meine Damen und Herren hören Sie eine
Ansprache des klickso Moderators
Christoph krachten nein nein nicht ganz
unser nächster Gast kann das viel besser
selbst denn es ist hallo Kinder ich bin
cy wolltet ihr nicht schon immer mal
wissen wie man so auf die Idee kommt
eine Synchro zu machen oder auch welches
Schnittprogramm man dafür benutzt oder
auch warum zum Teufel ich
Kunstwissenschaft studiere dann stellt
mir jetzt eure Fragen per
Videoantwort ich bin schon sehr gespannt
was sie glaube ich damit sagen will ist
lasst euch etwas einfallen kreativität
ist gefragt und stellt dir keine Fragen
wie sie 100 Millionen Mal gehört hat und
abonniert natürlich klicksum damit er
dann das Interview nicht verpasst wir
wissen noch nicht ganz genau wann wir zu
ihr fahren aber demnächst ist es der
Fall und bis dahin lasst eurer
Kreativität freien Lauf stellt Fragen
die noch nie fragt worden sind an C cold
mirror viel
Spaß